[Applause]
I mean I feel like the Epiphany lesson
is so clear in that book and it comes in
the very first chapter when you talk
about going to a Jim Brown movie now
yeah I don't know if people of a certain
age don't know who Jim Brown is but Jim
Brown was the original athlete turn star
yeah before that I think Mickey Mantle
never became a movie star yeah it was
always a joke when they put a guy like
right yeah and then it became much more
of a common thing when you see okay Jim
Brown and he was I mean I wanted to be
Jim Brown too when he was in 100 Rifles
yeah yeah Raquel Welch and she's oh
there it is oh oh that's the oh look at
that that's the poster oh yeah where
she's hugging him from behind like that
and they both have a look on their face
like yeah we just did it and we did it
well
no they're sexy in that movie oh and
he's very sexy okay so you saw a Jim
Brown movie yeah when you were how old
were you probably like 10 I was 72 so I
I'm like uh
uh eight eight years old yeah you're in
this all black theater okay and it's a
double feature when they had double feet
yeah and the first movie is is kind of a
messaging movie yeah it's called the bus
is coming but the bus is coming
the crowd hated it
hated it right they're literally yelling
out suck my dick yeah right yeah okay
well it was the you know uh I was a
fairly sophisticated kid so I've seen
the adults kind of you know uh have
different responses you know
um uh to movies before and I've even
seen an audience turn against an adult
audience turn against the movie but I'd
never seen the level of contempt that
this black audience felt towards the
bust is coming I mean they just which is
a black movie yes they just proceeded to
just yell insults at the characters on
screen
because like it was that's not the movie
we came to see so we only walked in so
uh so we had 45 minutes to go so for the
whole 45 minutes they just yelled [ __ ]
at the people on screen and the first
time I ever heard the expression suck my
dick all right it was like some guy in
the audience yelling it to somebody in
the on on screen
and at first I'm a little trepidatious
about it all in a rape suck my hair this
is quite an education you're getting
well I'm a little trepidatious but all
at a certain point they were just so
funny I just started like uncontrollably
giggling and then like you know and you
know and the guy who's taking me to see
it is this football player who's dating
my mom so he's trying to get in good
with me and he takes me in an all black
theater and he sees me like being
comfortable he's like hey you a cool kid
Q you know and he's like Pat me with
this huge hand and uh uh uh and so uh so
I yell out something at the screen kind
of look at him to make sure it's okay
he's like you know he's like happy that
I'm having a good time so I suck my dick
hey characters but actually the funniest
one definitely had the benefit of being
memorable all right uh but the funniest
one is at the end of the movie The Bus
which I think was supposed to be a
metaphor and this 12 year old kids
waiting for the bus the whole film all
right uh uh at the end the bus finally
shows up and then the kid runs down the
street screaming the title of the movie
the bus is covering the bus is coming
the bus is coming and somebody in the
theater just says yeah we'll get on it
and go [ __ ] yourself
I just want to say uh
if you're promoting this book on The
Today Show don't tell these stories
[Laughter]
this movie comes on
a kick-ass action movie I'm sure where
he's cool and and the crowd loves it and
you say you have never been the same
yeah well your whole career yeah you've
been trying to recreate that experience
from 1972. it was a magnificent
experience especially being the you know
uh the son of a of a single mother you
know and then and even at that point uh
she was living with two of her best
friends so it's like a house with three
young women
uh so being taken by a football player
like a Rams player I do a Jim Brown
movie uh in 1972 on a Saturday night in
an all-black theater except for me uh
that was probably the most masculine
male experience I had ever had in my
life I was like [ __ ] going camping this
is it yeah this is
this is way better than [ __ ] fishing
all right uh this is this is cool I mean
but but you know but there is an aspect
I do say that it's like you know either
as a movie consumer going to movies and
being part of an audience or creating
movies for an audience that that goal of
a gym Brown movie in 1972 on a Saturday
night is always what I'm trying to
achieve and to me it also read like it's
a
it's important to make I love a
meaningful movie I can't stand one that
isn't yeah usually sometimes something
to be just silly and I can enjoy but
mostly I want to get into something yeah
but don't forget we're entertainers
absolutely that to me was the lesson
there the first one just wasn't
entertaining and if you don't entertain
people it doesn't matter how good the
message is that you're just preaching
and we're [ __ ] bored absolutely and
the second one well it's entertaining
and you certainly
if nothing else and you've been much
else have been energy